the jury has reached the verdict and it
is damning
this report of the intergovernmental
panel on climate change
is a litany of broken climate promises
it is a file of shame cataloging the
empty pledges that put us firmly on
track towards an unbelievable world
we are on a fast track to climate
disaster
measures heat is underwater
unprecedented waves terrifying storms
widespread water shortages the
extinction of a million species of
plants and animals
and these is not fiction or exaggeration
it is what science tells us will result
from our current energy policies
we are on a pathway to global warming of
more than doubled 1.5 degree limit
agreed in paris
some government and business leaders are
saying one thing
but between another
simply put
they are lying
and results will be catastrophic
this is a climate emergency
climate scientists warn that we are
already perilously close to tipping
points that could lead to cascading and
irreversible climate impacts
but high meeting governments and
corporations are not just turning a
blind eye
they are adding full to the flames
they are choking our planet based on
their vested interests and historic
investments in fossil fuels
when cheaper renewable solutions provide
green jobs energy security and greater
price stability
we left cop 26 in glasgow with the naive
optimism based on new promises and
commitments
but the main problem
the enormous growing emissions gap was
all but ignored
and the science is clear to keep 1.5
degrees limit agreed in paris within
reach we need to clap global emissions
by 45 percent this decade
but current climate pledges would mean a
14
increase in emissions
and most measuring meters are not taking
the steps needed to fulfill even these
inadequate promises
climate activists are sometimes depicted
as dangerous radicals
but the truly dangerous radicals are the
countries that are increasing the
production of fossil fuels
investing in new fossil fuel
infrastructure is moral and economic
madness
such investments will soon be stranded
assets a blot on the landscape and the
blight on investment portfolios
but it doesn't have to be this way
today's report is focused on mitigation
cutting emissions it sets out viable
financially sound options in every
sector that can keep the possibility of
limiting warming to 1.5 degrees alive
first and foremost we must triple the
speed of the shift to renewable energy
and that means moving investments and
subsidies from fossil fuels to
renewables now
in most cases renewables are already far
cheaper
it means governments ending the funding
of coal not just abroad but at home
and it means climate coalitions made out
of developed countries multilateral
development banks private financial
institutions and corporations with
adequate technologies supporting major
economic emerging economies in making
this shift
it means protecting forests and
ecosystems as powerful climate solutions
it means rapid progress in reducing
methane emissions and it means
implementing the pledges made in paris
and glasgow
leaders must live
but all of us can do our part we owe
adapt to young people civil society and
indigenous communities for sounding the
alarm and holding leaders accountable
we need to build on their work to create
a grassroots movement that cannot be
ignored
if you live in a big city a rural area
or a small island state
if you invest in the stock market if you
care about justice and our children's
future i am appealing directly to you
demand that renewable energy is
introduced now at speed and at scale
demand an end to coal-fired power
demand an end to all fossil fuel
subsidies
today's report comes at the time of
global turbulence inequalities are at
unprecedented levels the recovery from
the profit 19 pandemic is scandalously
uneven inflation is rising and war in
ukraine is causing food and energy
prices to skyrocket
but increasing fossil fuel production
will only make matters worse
choices made by countries now
will make or break the commitment to 1.5
degrees
a shift to renewables will mend our
broken global energy mix and offer hope
to millions of people suffering climate
impacts today
climate promises and plans must be
turned into reality and action now
it's time to stop burning our planet and
start investing in the abundant
renewable energy all around us